[Music]
you know what this catchy music means
it's ps plus time again playstation plus
subscribers can download the following
games when the store updates in your
country
on the first tuesday of the month which
is april the 6th you ready
let's do this the first game is oddworld
soulstorm
a brand spanking new game we receive on
the day it is released
let's quickly put something straight
although this is a ps4 and a ps5 game
it's only the ps5 version which is on ps
plus
yeah kind of sucky but sony's focus is
to get us all onto next-gen hardware
and an extra game each month is part of
their plan
oddworld soulstorm is a puzzle-solving
side-scroller in which we
abe free the slaves these are madokans
which there are over 1 000 of
and abe must protect them they are more
like lemmings if i'm honest
over time we can teach these minions how
to fight back and be part of the
revolution
some lock doors require a certain amount
of medukens to survive
in order to open so you'll need to at
least try to protect most of them
abe can scavenge pickpocket and loot
items in order to craft his own arsenal
instead of running away from threats to
add tense battles to the formula
which is where the dual sense
controller's haptics are used
to feel abe's heartbeat when stressed or
in high alert adding a layer of suspense
to the gameplay
as oddworld soulstorm is a new game
there aren't any reviews to help us out
but you should know the previous game in
the series averaged 8.7 out of 10 across
all the main media outlets
so things look good we should probably
try this are you gonna
next up is days gone this one is already
available to those on ps5
but now it's here on ps4 too we play as
a biker deacon saint john
two years after the zombie apocalypse
struck these
freakers make up the bulk of the enemies
you face with their mindless aggression
and horde mentality
i mean these guys will hunt you down in
packs deacon can fight back with
firearms melee and
improvised weapons and when those things
aren't hot on your heels
it's those pesky humans instead luckily
in this open world there are trustworthy
people
in camps for us to discover which leads
on to our motorbike
deke's machine is the key to progression
not only is this your means of travel
it's your inventory too with slots for
your gear that deacon can't carry alone
and this beast can be upgraded and
personalized on your way through the
game
on release days gone was not a great
experience i'll be honest but over time
the updates have made this a must play
for all playstation gamers reviews range
from five to eight out of ten
if you can forgive the repetitive
missions and a few mechanical flaws this
is definitely a game you should try and
finally more undead
zombie army 4 dead war i won't lie
i adore this game series taking on the
undead with slow motion snipes to the um
the head is unbelievably satisfying it's
essentially the sniper elite games
thrown into an alternative universe in
which world war ii
is basically the living versus hell's
undead
the campaign has you hunting down the
dude with the tash
i'm not going to say his name because
youtube won't like it
fighting through all his minions in over
the top scenarios both solo and with
friends
and that's where the game hits its
stride the multiplayer missions they
make for some of the most tactical
last gasp final few bullets in your
weapon kind of antics
as the respawning hordes edge ever
closer there's also an
undead shark zombie army 4 may not hold
your attention for very long but it will
entertain you
so what do you think happy sad delighted
glad please sound off in the comments
i'm hyped for soul storm and seeing more
people play zombie army 4 online
makes me happy too please look out for
me in multiplayer matches
i'm adam from playstation grenade i'll
see you next time
[Music]